this right here is a picture of
Fibonacci Fibonacci one of the most
famous mathematicians of all time and he
was a mathematician in medieval Italy
and he is most famous for the Fibonacci
numbers Fibonacci Fibonacci numbers and
he didn't discover them they were
actually discovered several centuries
before him in India but he popularized
them especially in the West and the
Fibonacci numbers are super simple the
first two are defined as 0 and 1 and
every number after that is the sum of
the previous two so what I'm
constructing right here is really a
Fibonacci sequence of numbers so the
next number in the sequence is going to
be 0 plus 1 which is 1 then the next
number after that is going to be 1 plus
1 which is 2 then the next number after
that 1 plus 2 is 3 2 plus 3 is 5 3 plus
5 is 8 5 plus 8 is 13 8 plus 13 is 21 13
13 plus 21 is 34 and the Fibonacci
numbers you know especially once you
start getting into number theories tons
of fascinating things about them but
probably the coolest thing about them is
as you add more and more terms to the
Fibonacci sequence and you take the last
two terms that you've generated you
obviously there is no really last two
terms you could keep going on forever
get arbitrarily large Fibonacci numbers
but say we take these last two terms
over here 21 21 and 34 if we take the
ratio of these two 21 over 34 this is
going to be pretty close pretty close to
the golden ratio pretty close to the
golden ratio and I encourage you to look
up the golden ratio on Wikipedia and the
internet you'll find all sorts of
fascinating and mystical things about
the golden ratio what's cool about the
Fibonacci numbers or the Fibonacci
sequence this gives you an approximation
of the golden ratio we're going to
better even a better approximation if
you if you add another seek term to our
sequence so the next term over here 21
plus 34 is 55 so the ratio of 34 to 55
is even closer even closer to the golden
ratio
so one way if you wanted to compute a
really good approximation for the gold
ratio you can really just get super -
Bonacci numbers just adding the you know
the previous two terms to get the next
one and you will get a pretty good
approximation when you take the ratio of
the last two terms now that's what the
Fibonacci numbers are about and what now
I want to pose a challenge to you I want
you to write since we've already done
some examples using factorial I want you
to write an implementation of a function
that generates the nth term in the
Fibonacci sequence so the function will
be like this so this will be in the
Fibonacci sequence so if I call your
function let me make it lowercase let me
just give you some examples so if I take
your function and I call Fibonacci
Fibonacci and you can really implement
this in any language you want although
we've been dealing in Python it might be
simplest to do it in Python if I call
Fibonacci of Fibonacci of 1 what I want
this to be is the first term and just to
make things clear and you should always
clarify this especially in computer
science because it's not always clear
what the first term is and I'm going to
make it clear right now the first term
is not going to be this one over here
I'm going to make it this one over here
I'm going to call this I'm going to call
this the zeroth term that's the zeroth
term and then that is going to be the
first term this is going to be the
second term third term fourth term so on
and so forth and so Fibonacci of 1 the
first term will be this right over here
it will it should return one Fibonacci
of 0 so Fibonacci of 0 should return 0
Fibonacci of 3 should return 0 1 2 3 it
should return to Fibonacci Fibonacci
Fibonacci of 5 should return 0 1 2 3 4 5
it should actually return 5 and what I
want you to do is write a function so we
could put in any argument over here and
we'll return that third term of the
Fibonacci sequence